[Music]
when I first started acting and when
every actor first starts out you take a
job any job anywhere I was for so many
years you know clerk or party boy number
two or a kid student behind girl you
know and things like that you didn't
have any names and then hopefully
eventually you break through and you get
a name character and you actually have a
little more character depth and if all
goes well and you get lucky you you can
actually have a bona fide character and
you're on your way hopefully it's not
it's not a guarantee but it's it's what
you strive for and you take the jobs as
they come if by chance you get struck by
lightning as I did and you have this
unbelievable unexpected success in a
couple series that were big hits one
comedy one drama and then you go on and
you're able to do Broadway and you're
able to do other movies starring in
movies and things Wow
what what a god-sent what what great
good fortune along with that is the
energy comes out when you're just
starting out and for most actors most
actors are sending out information who's
doing what where are the auditions how
can I get in where you're constantly
sending information out to see if you
can get a piece of this here and there
if you get lucky that energy that you
were sending out turns around and comes
back at you and now that's what's
happened to me is that instead of me
sending information out to find out
where things are it's coming to me
in equal amounts of energy used I'm like
oh well yes what oh ok hang on let me
see you later a great opportunity don't
get me wrong it's a great place to be
but there's a lot of energy spent in
trying to read this and and field offers
of the cut that are coming to
so I had to figure out a system that
made sense to me that gave a like you
said in analytical Vout evaluation to it
and and this is what I came up with I
called it a cap system a cranston
assessment of projects system caps it
wasn't intended for anybody else but if
anybody else finds it useful they
welcome to have it and I gave a
numerical value to the things that I
found to be the most important and the
most important is the story the writing
is the is the the single most important
element in any performance art I don't
see an exception to that
I think Meryl Streep at her best acting
if she was given c-level material she
could definitely make that a B but
that's it that's how far you can go with
c-level material you can enhance it you
can bring that up to a B if you start
with a level material oh baby
that's that's ooh that's fantastic so I
wanted to evaluate the projects that
were coming in
according to story text and then the
character then the director and then
other elements like who else is in the
cast but things like personal how long
where is it shooting how long would it
take me away from my home and my family
that sort of thing it was important for
me to to you know navigate through all
those things so that's how I came up
with the system and and it works for me
I give a numerical evaluation to every
project it comes through
[Music]
you